gas station meat I'm out on are you
kidding me gas station Fried Chicken top
tier food top tier you you never you
weren't in that phase in the South those
gas stations are like fullblown markets
they have some of the best food dude
ever have you seen the people working at
the gas stations yeah they put a lot of
they put a lot of love into that food
you think they're taking care with the
cleanliness of they're making and I
don't blame them they're making minimum
wage they get [__] on every day they are
not making sure that you are Health
grade quality a at the gas station
Southern gas station
food I'm sure it's delicious it's
amazing I'm not saying it's not good but
I'm just saying it they they should just
name that explosive di there's a gas
station in La some of the best Frick can
ever had yeah I'm just not you got to go
right at noon though or else it gets
soggy yeah yeah but they're so good
fresh out oh my God zero chance yeah
yeah I love gas station frag